Hey guys welcome back, thanks for joining me today on the king of random our experiment today is something
I'm very excited to try because it's something I've wondered about for a long time
I've often wondered how different things would burn in a vacuum chamber, but it's really hard to get something ignited inside there
You can't really have a blowtorch because there's no way to turn it on and it's adding fuel which is gonna make vapors and you
Can't really light matches inside because you can't reach in while it's a vacuum
I think the Soraa scorcher is the perfect solution for that the focus light from the solar scorcher will add heat inside the vacuum chamber
But no fuel or anything with mass so it should work to light things on fire
The question is what happens after they start burning so the purpose of today's video is to see if we can cook
Marshmallows in our simulated outer space after we're finished with the marshmallows
We'll probably try throwing a few more things in the vacuum chambers
See what happens if you burn them without any air or pressure of course to be using the solar scorcher we need sunlight
So let's head outside. We've got a vacuum chamber. We've got a solar scorcher and now that we're outside. We've got some good sunshine
Let's see how marshmallows cook in outer space in a jar oh
There's our marshmallow already growing
They grow up so fast oh
And now it's collapsing back down again
All right this little jar pulls a vacuum pretty fast
We go our gauge is saying that we have about 26 inches of mercury of negative pressure in there so now
Let's see if we can cook our marshmallow
through the glass
All right, I can focus it more than that but I'm sure that would just burn the marshmallow right away
I'm trying to see if I could get kind of a nice cooked surface on it
You know what just to make sure that it is doing something
I am gonna focus in a dot and see if the marshmallow burns. Oh
Yep, it burns
Look at that smoke it didn't like travel anywhere. Just kind of just hanging around in the same spot
Let's do that again for some more smoke
That's a neat little effect, and now it's like falling to the bottom
I kind of thought it would just instantly fill the whole container since the
container has no air in it and
Now the dark spots on the marshmallow are burning more than the light spots because they absorb more of the heat
Focus off of those a little bit think I'm getting a pretty good result if I almost focus it into a point
You know what that's too much fun. I'm just gonna make a lot of smoke
That's so funny the way it just like shoots up like that it's so fun a
Smoke is settling at the bottom. I guess the smoke has mass and there's nothing else for it to rise above
So it just stays at the bottom make some more
Think now I'm mostly just burning splattered marshmallow on the side of the glass all right, let's repress your eyes
Oh, it smells like marshmallow it smells like burnt marshmallow
That's the funkiest looking oh
That is so weird the crystallized sugar kind of holds its shape, but the rest of the marshmallow doesn't at all
So it just kind of collapsed around the burned portions
It's so sad looking almost like a weirdly
Large piece of popcorn well, I'm gonna eat it
Mmm. There's like burnt sugar
There you go using sunlight to cook marshmallows in our simulated outer space the result is that while you can cook them?
It's very slow
it's very hard to do evenly and the heat doesn't distribute through the marshmallow very well at all, so you just get kind of a
Shrunken raisin husk of a marshmallow with a little bit of cooked parts on it
However the solar scorcher is putting heat through the glass into the vacuum chamber
So let's try some other things in there and see how well they burn to protect the glass of a vacuum jar
I've got a piece of styrofoam of an inch thick and some foil I'm just gonna wrap the foil around the styrofoam and use that
To put stuff on while I burn it the first thing. I'm gonna try burning is some matches obviously in a vacuum
There's not going to be any oxygen of pressure
But hopefully the match heads will still at least ignite a little bit when they're hit with the heat from solar scorcher
And hit this first match here see what happens with concentrated sunlight
Not a whole lot
Smoke flew off of it, but it didn't flare up even a little bit. I thought that some
Like I thought we would see it burning a little bit more than that let's try this next one
See the smoke looks. Oh there goes faster
So there is a fast point where it goes off. That's something all right one more
There it goes
The texture on that is pretty interesting. It doesn't look anything like a normal burned match
It's like I dip it in glue and then stuck a bunch of sand to it or something
Next up was try lighting a little bit of firework fuse the match heads had a really hard time lighting
So I'm not sure if the fuse is going to be able to pass its ignition
down the line
Kind of here it
It's still burning it's burning slower than normal
But it is burning all that smoke is really thick Oh
Saw some movement down at the bottom. I think the fuse got short enough that it's burning started propelling it around on the bottom
Launched itself off
That a nice smoke spot on our lid
Fuses make a lot of smoke apparently wow
There's a little bit of remnants in there, but for the most part the fuse is gone
So I think it burns slower than normal, but it did burn good to know
Well, that's so thick look at the difference of this
What I've wiped it off
Very big smoke that builds up on the walls if you smoked a lot
We're gonna try and one-up that by just lighting off some of our colored smoke powder
Normally the smoke powder has a chain reaction if you ignite just one part of it and the whole thing will get lit I kind
Of don't think it's gonna work that way with this stuff
We're definitely getting smoke that parts for sure see if it keeps itself going at all
Nope, it's gone out pretty much completely and for whatever reason it keeps spraying the smoke right at the glass
It makes it harder to heat up. This kind of cool. You can see the whole focus point
through the smoke though oh
Yeah, look at that and see that our glass focus from the solar scorcher definitely starts burning it definitely gives off smoke it
Just won't burn the rest of it in a chain reaction
I
Have here some of our zinc and sulfur rocket fuel which we showed you how to make in a previous video and launch pan rockets
With I'm gonna see if I can like this with the solar scorcher in the vacuum chamber
I
Like the smoke powdery, it it reacts
But it doesn't have the ability to have the super fast reaction than we would expect oh
Oh, that's zinc oxide or sulfide
It reacted we can't see any of it because its covered in smoke
But it reacted definitely took a lot more heat check this out Green Smoke on the side of the container
And we have really no idea what happened we have a slow-mo camera
We can look at that, but I think it's just gonna get obscured in slo-mo
That looks pretty gnarly
Check that out
He zinc sulfide
Formed in a vacuum. That's a much larger
Structure than we were getting we just lift this off by itself
I talked about how the smoke from the fuse was fairly opaque, look at this like you can't you can't see through that at all
There's a solid
block of powder
There is one more thing
I want to try and that's igniting thermite in a vacuum, now thermite should provide its own oxygen
And so it shouldn't matter if there is any in there already. Let's find out
Tiny little spark
That's interesting
Oh! kind of got a reaction going a
Few little beads formed and fell into the bottom of the cup. I thought I was gonna start more of it, but oh
We got a chain reaction a little one a short little
fairly boring for thermite reaction hey it did light
That's the progress we wanted there you have it simulated outer space really stops a lot of stuff from burning
It was tough to get our marshmallows to cook evenly we could get them to burn and we got some really cool smoke patterns flying
Off of it
Matches didn't really want to burn very well
Fuse burned very slowly and put off a lot of smoke our colored smoke powder would make colored smoke
But only as long as the focal point from the fernell ends was really pointed right at it
Eventually we did get our rocket fuel to light that was kind of cool
It made some green smoke, which stained the side of our vacuum chamber
But it wasn't nearly as energetic or fast of a reaction as we normally get and then we tried lighting thermite
Which we got some reaction out of we got some cool sparks
We did eventually get it to react and form a little puddle of iron at the bottom of our miniature pot
But it wasn't nearly as exciting as if you just light it in a normal pressurized oxygen-rich environment
If you ever find yourself floating around in outer space definitely don't try and cook anything and tell you're back in a pressurized environment
Probably be the least of your worries
Thanks for joining us for this experiment today, and we'll see you in the next one talk to you then
It's a monster marshmallow and
It's dying hmm. I think it's cooked
Yeah, you can see it from the top that works pretty well
Hey guys, it's grant here, I just want to pop in and say hello
You guys are wonderful Nate, and I are incredibly grateful for the way. You keep supporting us, so that's pretty much
It just want to give you a quick. Thank you. I'll see in the next video